hi I'm Joe Russo and I'm Anthony Russo
we're here for and dango movieclips
things to know before you check out our
new film Captain America Civil War in
Captain America Civil War the Avengers
are basically split into one side led by
Captain America one side led by Iron Man
and this division and the Avengers is
very important in terms of how we move
the Marvel Cinematic Universe forward
into infinity war they're about to face
the greatest threat the world the
universe has ever seen an infinity war
and to have a divided Avengers when that
threat comes as a very danger it's
significant can they repair their
relationships should they repair their
relationships being brothers you know
the way we've thought about this movie
is as a family unit and civil war we've
always thought about as a fight within a
family and that's one reason why we
think the story is very relevant and
emotional because these are very
intimate relationships between these
characters that have developed over many
movies now and to get them to a place
and our storytelling where we're now
going to figure out how they have to
deal with one another as an antagonist
as opposed to a traditional villain seem
very exciting to us as filmmakers so
that's where this story runs the way we
were able to pick sides is that we
actually sat in a room with the writers
and thought long and hard about what we
could do that would be honest and
truthful to the characters and at the
same time with surprise the audience so
hopefully when you go see the movie
some of some of your favorites are are
supporting your other favorite
characters but you'll be surprised by a
couple of choices that a few of the
Marvel Universe characters make if
you're a big fan of spider-man as I was
I collected comic books growing up and I
still have my collection in my closet he
was my favorite character I loved the
fact that he was so young that it was a
high schoolers burden with all of this
incredible power and that was very
important to us in our interpretation of
the character we wanted to make sure
that we found an actor was very close in
age to Peter Parker we found a wonderful
actor and Tom Holland who was able to
embody that vulnerable
that insecurity in that humor that sense
of fun and we wrap it all up into a new
interpretation of spider-man one of the
great things about making Marvel movie
is that you can rely up how you can draw
upon work that's been done by great
writers and artists for decades now so
it like in Captain America this movie
civil war is based on one of Marvel's
best-selling comics ever Civil War and
we were able to take some very special
things from that book including the
concept the very fun concept of fan
fantasy concept of all their favorite
superheroes going to war with one
another but the thing that we always
really think is important is we don't
want to give you a simply a retelling of
what you saw in the comics we want to
give you a fresh original story that's
very much of today and of the moments
and that's what we try to do this for
well that wraps things up for us Anthony
and Joe Russo the Russo brothers and
thanks for watching things to know
before seeing Captain America Civil War
you
you